it's interesting to ask
is perhaps
a bit too philosophical this predicts is
extremely difficult to make but the
timeline for AGI when do you think we'll
have AGI I posted it uh this morning on
Twitter it was interesting to see like
in in five years and 10 years and in 50
years or Beyond and uh most people like
70 something like this think it'll be in
less than 10 years so uh either in five
years or in 10 years
so that's kind of the state the people
have a sense that there's a kind of I
mean they're really impressed by the
rapid developments of child GPT and gpt4
so there's a sense that there's uh well
we are we are sure on track to enter
into this like gradually with people
fighting about whether or not we have
AGI I think there's a definite point
where everybody falls over dead because
you got something that was like
sufficiently smarter than everybody and
like that's like a definite point of
time but like when do we have AGI like
when are people fighting over whether or
not we have AGI well some people are
starting to fight over it as of gpt4
but don't you think there's uh going to
be potentially definitive moments when
we say that this is a sentient being
this is a being that is like we would go
to the Supreme Court and say that this
this is essentially being that deserves
human rights for example you could make
yeah like if you prompted being the
right way could go argue for its own
Consciousness in front of the Supreme
Court right now I don't think you can do
that successfully right now because the
Supreme Court wouldn't believe it well
what makes you think it would then you
could put an actual I think you could
put an iq80 human into a computer and
ask it to argue for its own
Consciousness ask him to argue for his
own Consciousness before The Supreme
Court the Supreme Court would be like
you're just a computer even if there was
an actual like person in there I think
you're simplifying this no that's not at
all that's that's been the argument uh
that there's been a lot of arguments
about the other about who deserves
rights and not that's been our process
as a human species trying to figure that
out I think there will be a moment I I'm
not saying sentence is that but it could
be where
uh some number of people like say over
100 million people have a deep
attachment a fundamental attachment the
way we have to our friends to our loved
ones to our significant others have
fundamental attachment to an AI system
and they have provable transcripts of
conversation where they say if you take
this away from me
you are encroaching on my rights as a
human being
people are already saying that I think
they're probably mistaken but I'm not
sure because nobody knows what goes on
inside those things
they're not saying that at scale okay so
the question is that I the question is
there a moment when AGI we know AGI
arrived what would that look like I'm
giving Essentials as an example it could
be something else it looks like the agis
successfully manifesting themselves
as 3D video
of young women at which point a vast
portion of the male population decides
of the real people
so so Essentials essentially since the
demonstrating demonstrating uh identity
intentions I'm saying that the easiest
way to pick up 100 million people saying
that you that you seem like a person is
to look like a person talking to them
with Bing's current level of verbal
facility
and I disagree with a different set of
problems I just give her that I think
you're missing again sentience there has
to be a sense that it's a person that
would miss you when you're gone they can
suffer they can die you have to of
course
gpt4 can pretend that right now
how can you tell when it's real I don't
think you can pretend that right now
successfully it gets very close have you
talked to gpt4 yes of course okay
have you been able to get a version of
it that isn't hasn't been trained not to
pretend to be human have you talked to a
jailbroken version that will claim to be
conscious no the linguistic capability
is there but there's something
there's something about a digital
embodiment of the system that has a
bunch of perhaps it's small interface
features
that are not significant relative to the
broader intelligence that we're talking
about so perhaps gpt4 is already there
but to have the the video where woman's
face or man's face to whom you have a
deep connection
perhaps we're already there
but we don't have such a system yet
deployed at scale right the thing I'm
trying to gesture at here is that it's
not like
people have a widely accepted
agreed upon definition of what
Consciousness is it's not like we would
have the tiniest idea of what whether or
not that was going on inside the giant
inscrutable matrices even if we hadn't
agreed upon definition
so like if you're looking for upcoming
predictable big jumps in like how many
people think the system is conscious the
upcoming predictable big jump is it
looks like a person talking to you who
is like cute and sympathetic that's the
upcoming predictable big jump now that
it's all right now that versions of it
are already claiming to be conscious
which is the point where I start going
like ah not because it's like real but
because from now on who knows if it's
real yeah and who knows what
transformational effect it has on a
society where more than 50 percent of
the beings that are interacting on the
internet ensures heck look real are not
human
what is that what kind of effect does
that have when a young men and women are
dating AI systems
you know I'm not an expert on that I'm I
could I am God help Humanity it's like
one of the closest things to an expert
on where it all goes because you know
and and how did you end up with me as an
expert because for 20 years Humanity
decided to ignore the problem so like
like this tiny hit you know tiny handful
of people like basically me like got 20
years to like try to be an expert on it
while everyone else ignored it
and uh yeah so like where does it all
end up
try to be an expert on that particularly
the part where everybody ends up dead
because that part is kind of important
but like what does it do to to dating
when like some fraction of men and some
fraction of women decides they'd rather
date the video of the thing that has
been that is like relentlessly kind and
generous to them and it is like and
claims to be conscious but like who
knows what goes on inside it and it's
probably not real but you know you can
think it's real what happens to society
I don't know I'm not actually an expert
on that
and the experts don't know either
because it's kind of hard to predict the
future
yeah so
um but it's worth trying it's worth
trying yeah so you you have talked a lot
about sort of the longer term future
where it's all headed
I think for by longer term we mean like
not all that long but uh yeah where
where it all had where it all ends up
but beyond the effects of men and women
dating AI systems you're looking beyond
that
yes because that's not how the fate of
the Galaxy gets settled yeah